[Music]
this pandemic is is is overwhelming it's
just so many people that need the
breathing machines that that just simply
haven't been manufactured yet
imagine you're a doctor and have a 30
year old patient and an 80 year old both
infected with the corona virus both
showing severe symptoms and both needing
an oxygen mask but you only have one who
do you choose this kind of decision is
called triage it's French and it means
deciding who has a higher chance of
survival and is given higher priority in
medical treatment and who might be left
to them it all comes down to how well a
health system is prepared for a pandemic
in the end it's the number of intensive
care beds and ventilators that counts
currently most health system outside
Italy and France are holding the line
but around the world hospitals are
filling up and triage might become a
reality for doctors sooner or later this
is the worst case scenario when treating
patients in France doctors are forced to
make life-or-death decisions
patients over the age of 80 who will not
be put on mechanical ventilators this
process is called triage the term comes
from the French verb ta
it means the sorting of and allocation
of treatment to patients modern medical
triage was invented during the
Napoleonic Wars
France Spain and Italy are the worst
affected countries in Europe more than
100,000 people have been infected with
the virus in Italy alone nearly 12,000
have died and the longer the crisis
continues the more often doctors are
faced with making some very tough
decisions and to talk about those
decisions I am now joined by dr. Tobias
court he's a physician and epidemic
epidemiologist and the director did and
also the director of the Institute for
public health at Berlin's Charity
Hospital and Professor Eva Winkler a
physician teaching medical ethics at
Heidelberg University let's start with
you dr. Cort we're not yet doing triage
in Germany our doctors well prepared
for taking these decisions well doctors
are well prepared as doctors in the
world and have good training and the
hospitals and physicians organization
prepare let's say a theoretical
framework I think when the triage is
necessary in in Germany it will be very
challenging for the doctors and the
medical teams here as well doctor how
does triage work in hospital is it just
one doctor who ends up being the only
one responsible and carries this burden
well they are certainly operating
procedures in place but you can imagine
eventually you have very short time to
decide in which case it will be left by
the treating physician and the medical
teams on the side who will get the
ventilator and who not so it's going to
be very challenging situation so
therefore the support of the local or
structures to hospital as well as the
legal system is very important to
support these medical teams to make
these decisions we're talking about
these procedures that professor Winkler
how conductors and hospital actually
prepare for triage well I think from an
ethical point of view and preparing for
these decisions is crucial for two
reasons because we need uniform rules in
order to ensure a fair allocation of
resources across teams across units and
hospitals and because doctors in their
everyday clinical work don't are not
familiar and not at ease with such
decisions because the traditional
clinical ethics is patient centered and
not apt for allocating patients to
different levels of contingency care so
from an ethical point of view we need to
agree on two areas I think first the
triage port costs that provide for
step-by-step evaluation and criteria for
prioritizing patients in Germany several
Medical Association published
recommendation for triage protocol last
week with the Academy for Ethics and
medicine in the lead and second each
hospital then has to define process how
these rules should be implemented
and we need therefore triage teams that
include the expertise of intensive care
physicians so maybe even clinical ethics
committees can support in setting up
these processes
I think the most important thing is as
thing is that doctors not there only the
individual doctor is not in charge for
the whole responsibility taking in these
decisions that's one key issue of course
but what about normal doctors say in the
community village doctors who have
covered patients do they also or might
they also face these ethical dilemmas
and I think not those that dissing the
decision on who gets on the ventilator
is obviously not the primary care
physician but they have other triage
decisions if there are many patients who
want to transfer to the hospitals I if
there are many patients in need so I
think the same criteria of seriousness
and and comorbidities that go into the
triage protocols in the hospitals can
also plan be applied in the periphery
for the normal primary care physician or
will be at least of importance for him
or her
dr. Coates coming back to you how well
can you predict actually whether a
person will probably die even if treated
isn't that also a bit of a lottery there
but there are certain physiologic
parameters medical history appeared with
the medical experience of the treating
physician that will help to support your
decision but there's no certainty that
the to be made decision is T is the
right one but also there's a learning
curve as we know from Italy in Spain
that the teams make different decisions
depending on the situation and learning
however I'm very convinced automatic
teams will do it very best to really do
this triage to the best of their
knowledge
professor Winkler coming back to you as
an ethicist what can you tell a
front-line doctor who's facing a
decision like that could you give us an
example well
think first it would be important to to
acknowledge that these are tough
decisions that are kind of at odds with
our common doctor's ethics and somehow
at rest the tragedy of such dilemmas and
then coming back to those rules and
protocols that we we have now set up
saying that there are different phases
of a pandemic and if you have not enough
ventilators for our patients in needs
you have to prioritize those whom you
are more certain that you will that they
will survive than others and there we
have clearly laid out criteria so that
as was a court said is the current
situation of the patient comorbidities
frailty ISM criteria but for example age
is not a criteria that went into our
recommendations in Germany and I think
the third thing that I would recommend
is make the doctor aware of available
supports in Psychological terms because
we know that this is really a stress a
moral and otherwise stressing situation
and these structures are build up now in
the hospital as well as to relieve the
stress that fits in triage situations
professor if of England doctor to be
escort thank you very much and hours
every day here's our science
correspondent stearic Williams with a
couple of answers to questions that you
have sent in keep them coming
today it's about how men and women can
be differently affected by Kovach
nineteen it's the Kovich gender gap
study suggests men are more likely to
catch Cova 19 than women is that true
it does indeed appear that men are more
likely to test positive for the disease
than women are in other words men make
up more than the 50% of confirmed cases
you would expect if the virus infected
men and women with equal frequency
are men more likely to die from Cova 19
as well here the data is is is more
conclusive and what it's saying is that
men are more likely to die after
infection with cope at 19 than women are
the numbers are very striking for
example in Italy where over 70% of the
confirmed patients who succumb to the
disease were men also the corona virus
really does appear to be more lethal for
men than it is for women so why are men
more vulnerable than women like so much
else about this virus we just don't know
enough at this point to really pin down
why it's killing more men than it is
women but researchers have hazarded some
guesses on average worldwide more than
women do men pursue behaviors that are
considered to be health risks like
smoking tobacco or we're drinking
alcohol as everyone should know those
risks those unhealthy behaviors can also
lead to what are called comorbidities
those are conditions like like
hypertension or a cardiovascular disease
or chronic lung disease many of the
victims of cope at 19 were elderly men
with comorbidities yet other researchers
are trying to cast some light on the
issue by focusing on the biological and
genetic differences between men and
women could estrogen be playing a
projective role for example maybe there
are also some well-documented immune
system differences between men and women
and what's most probable is that all of
those factors social behavioral
biological that they're all going to
play a role in why kovat 19 is hitting
men harder than it's hitting women
there's not going to be a simple
straightforward explanation